But it's important that we call out bad
bad things. No, it's not. Oh,
our eyes having a hard time pulling the
broom out for this one. That's not
great, man. That is not good.
He said crust is critical.
>> [laughter]
>> NO. NO. [screaming]
BAD. YOU STEP DOWN.
You step down, random podcast dude. You.
>> [music]
>> I want to start with the 2024 autopsy,
which you call an after-action review.
On this show in August, you told me this
about releasing the review, quote, we
have to do it to give people who
invested so much time, energy, and money
a sense of what happened and why we
lost.
Especially why we lost. So, what changed
between August and December? I
understand there are lessons, but those
are not the full report. Why not release
the full report? What's in the report
that you wouldn't want to publicize?
>> Yeah, there's no smoking gun in the
report, and I know that's that's what
everyone's so eager to learn the smoking
gun. Guess what, John?
>> there's no smoking gun, why wouldn't you
just release it then?
>> Because we want to keep the focus on the
lessons. At long last, the 2024 DNC
autopsy report has been released, and
>> Wow. it is kind of a disaster. As we had
discussed on this show, it turns out
that Paul Rivera, the person tapped by
DNC chair Ken Martin to produce this
report, just kind of hit the bed.
>> Ken Martin gets credit, I think, for
doing that. Like, it is belated, but he
put it out, he apologized, so that is
good. On the other hand,
the more I like read his statement and
read his Substack and then looked at the
report, like, he lied. He promised a
report, put his incompetent friend in
charge of it. The incompetent friend
created an incoherent product. Then Ken
announced that they weren't going to
release the report for reasons that had
nothing to do with the truth about why
they weren't releasing it. Then, when
anyone asked about it, including me, he
decided to not just lie, but gaslight
people into being like you're the
problem. Why don't you want to win? Why
are you looking in the past? And then
there's like an internal revolt at the
DNC and among donors and DNC members.
And so then they release this. Oh my
god, Ira, talking about the DNC. So, by
the way, spoiler alert, Ken Martin
stepping down from the DNC?
Oh, no, he's just about to step down or
he they're they're calling for him to
step down. Okay, okay, okay. They're
People are like supporting him. It's
like, yeah, they he completely [__]
up. It's all It's all complete
incompetence.
Why? Basically, the DNC is not taking
care of its donors. The The job of the
DNC chair is to take care of the donors
to party. That's the job of the DNC
chair, okay?
At long last, the 2024 DNC autopsy
report has been released and it is Is it
kind of a disaster? I These guys are
going to find any way to attack it. You
know, what a what a real These guys are
a piece of work, man. I What side are
you on? Right? Like just take a step
back for a
Does Ira I know? I Ira I should know.
What What heck inside are you on, man?
Just take a step back and really look at
yourself and your party. Oh, come on,
man. Come on, man. What side are you on,
man? Holy sh
They They scream about Ken Martin not
releasing it forever. Then he releases
it and they still call it a disaster.
Like this stuff
Like
Dude, Ira I should know. Ira I should
know this that these guys are like party
insiders. That they know a bunch of
people. That they know donors. That the
reason they're causing a stink about
this is cuz they've heard this was
bungled horribly and they need to get
the party back on track.
That's why they're making a stink about
it. The donors want a stink made about
it.
Yes, the donors want people held
accountable for how sh this is.
That stuff adds up, man. It starts to
make people hate on the Democrats and
the left. And do you want the Democrats
to win or are you okay with them losing?
You know, people say all
>> [laughter]
>> I just don't Guys, if you criticize
Democrat Party, you want them to lose.
They You just want them to lose, man.
Don't Don't make it better.
>> don't be a shill, dude. Come on, we need
to be able to criticize our side. She
Yes, but you need to couch it with
compliments and say what's going well
and talk about why you still support the
party.
What's going well? What's going well?
>> Because obviously these chuckle do and
yet they act like they hate the party
every time they get on camera about
this.
Obnoxious. It's fine to be critical, but
how You got to also The only thing going
well is that you may have you may have
the least popular president ever in
American history, like driving your
country into the dirt right now. That's
the only thing that's going well. Also
say why you support and why it's
important you continue to support the
left.
I I can't stand this
this this
um
just this strange mentality on the left
that we're helping by criticizing
incessantly
and never offering anything good ever.
Ever. It's just constant tears and
criticism and they think they're helping
for some reason. It's It's the saddest,
stupidest loser mentality ever.
This was a complete screw up. He
originally said he would release it,
then he didn't, now he's releasing it.
So what? He said if he would never do
anything that he thought would be would
not help. And he didn't think releasing
the report would help. And now he
decided to release it. And he said
"Sorry, I should have done it. So,
what's the big deal?" I I
>> [laughter]
>> Did he I Dude, I don't even know if he
said that. I don't even know I actually
don't know if that's something he said.
I maybe should have watched it first.
But it's like, this guy really [__]
up. SO WHAT? BY THE WAY, I don't even
think they're that mad about the report
itself. It's more of like what all of
this means. It's that Ken Martin is not
getting money into the party. The The
party or Lots of the big donors wanted
to see this report to see what the [__]
went wrong. So they could know how much
to trust the Democratic Party moving
forward. The Releasing the report is
step one.
I I'm going to tell you, it looks real
bad when you release the report and the
report is basically like, "Yeah, we just
didn't really, you know, we just wanted
to do this for free. We let We handed it
off to somebody else who's going to do
it."
They totally [__] it up. I don't see
why Why are people not celebrating him
for changing course and releasing it?
Instead, they still attack him. It's
still not good enough, right? Like,
that's insane to me, dude. Um I think
you're not releasing this because you
guys [__] it up and you guys are
incompetent and I want I want heads to
roll for this. Okay, fine, I'll release
it then. Oh, so you were incompetent.
Okay, I want heads to roll for this. I I
WAS LIKE, "COME ON, MAN. NOTHING'S GOOD
ENOUGH FOR YOU GUYS. COME ON. ISN'T IT
GOOD? I THOUGHT HE CHANGED HIS MIND.
He's releasing IT. WHAT WHAT DO YOU
WANT?" Uh the people to have done a good
job in the first place.
Like, literally, the reason it wasn't
being released is because they didn't
want to be held accountable for the
results. Now it's being released and you
want to hold them accountable for the
results and
Technically, I think Ken Martin wasn't
the person who ordered it made, so
perfect metaphor for an institutional
Democratic Party that seems unwilling to
even face the moment. Disclaimer, this
document reflects the views of the
author, not the DNC. The DNC was not
provided with the underlying sourcing,
interviews, or supporting data for many
of the assertions contained herein and
therefore cannot independently verify
the claims presented. Conclusion,
this section is is provided by the
author.
>> [laughter]
>> It what?
Are you telling me they had a page that
says conclusion?
And then it's just empty? That's not
That's not true.
There's no possible way.
There's no possible way they've got a
conclusion and then it's just empty.
Uh-huh.
Yeah, okay.
Surely this can't be the document that
has the lessons of actually everybody
loves billionaires, man. Everybody loves
Don't talk about billionaires. Everybody
loves billionaires. It couldn't be that,
right? With no data, with no polling.
They just went everybody loves
billionaires actually. No way. Not
possible. People think the report was
heavily AI generated. Oh boy. Oh boy.
Greetings, Montreal.
I'm more mad that this report was so bad
useless.
Okay, but do you understand my
frustration that people are just
dogpiling on Ken Martin and the DNC? And
how does that help us in any way? It
just makes the left look bad. And you
go, "Well, what But it's important that
we call out bad bad things." No, it's
not. Do you think you need to tell your
partner every time they cook dinner that
it's not good? Or if they do something
bad, you need to tell them about it
every time? You better You If you want
to be happy, you better couch that with
some compliments, too.
You know what I mean? You You better say
something nice if you want to go there.
Yeah, guys, if you just expect us to see
our faults and get better acknowledge
our faults and get better, you're wrong.
I need some I need some sugar to make
the medicine go down, okay? Give me the
sugar or I won't take the medicine.
Go try that in anything else in life.
Just
criticize nonstop and then wonder why
people don't vote for your party. Why is
nobody voting for the Democrats? I don't
know, cuz you [__] on them for two
straight years. What do you mean? Well,
they were making mistakes and I felt I
needed to call it out. Well, what did
what did that accomplish? All you got is
people angry at the Democrats. Well,
they need to do better, dude. They need
to win me over. They need to do so much.
I
Why is Ira's entire job to argue that
politicians shouldn't politic?
COME ON. WHY DO YOU GUYS WANT ME TO DO
WORK? WHY YOU GUYS WANT DEMOCRATS TO DO
WORK, MAN? COME ON, MAN. That seems
really messed up. All right, come on,
man. You want me to do work and stuff,
man? Come on, man. I and and I demand
perfection. I don't see any positive
things, even though I haven't looked and
I don't even bother trying.
It's
It's crazy, man. I'm so tired of this
[__]
I'm so tired of it. This is not good
enough at all. I feel absolutely
defrauded by these political entities
and feel like I have suffered serious
damage. Please be sure to clip this so
we can use it when we submit our claims
to the anti-weaponization free payouts
fund. Thanks. They're mad because it
didn't mention Israel  Gaza, but
they can't say that so they act like
their criticism is something else.
That person
Destiny watching Julian. No actual
engagement with reality or politics at
all. Just Just Hassan is bad, Israel's
good, Palestine is bad, Palestine
supporters are bad. No engagement with
the real world. This was never, at least
for Pod Save, literally never about
Palestine. Ever. Ever. Ever. If you
think that, you have a
feeding you your political thoughts.
Absolute facts, Nico. I agree and I
called it a mile away. I said, "When the
report comes out, and it inevitably
will, it's not going to mention Gaza and
Israel
in the way these guys want it to, and
they'll move the goalposts and be mad
about something else.
Gappy, thank you for the resub, bro.
Appreciate that, man.
As we had discussed on the show, it
turns out that Paul Rivera, the person
tapped by the DNC, by DNC chair Ken
Martin, to produce this report, just
kind of [__] the bed, and turned in
>> He's already been surpassed by AI. Yes,
he turned in this incomplete analysis.
It's riddled with errors. It's not
backed by source materials. It's
seemingly So then wasn't it smart for
Ken Martin not to release it if it's
riddled with errors and it's not good
and it was just a bad report? Why
bother? He He put out the lessons
learned. So maybe he was right to not
put this out. Well, I I think probably
what they should have been doing, in my
opinion at least, was actually having
some oversight on it, right? Not just
farming it out to a donor, which is
apparently what happened.
>> the centerpiece of his campaign for DNC
chair, then handed it to a buddy working
part-time who never even interviewed
Harris or Waltz. The DNC is now
disowning their own report. Incredible.
>> [laughter]
>> Well, look, it it sounds like some
mistakes were made, which happen.
Uh-huh.
Sorry, sorry.
>> [clears throat and cough]
>> Hold on, hold on, hold on.
Destiny, look this. Turns out the report
the our reporting was correct.
Shout out @mattberg. This is exactly why
it didn't matter if it was released.
Nothing short of Israel-Palestine was
the sole reason Kamala lost would have
satisfied the people most obsessed with
this report.
Okay, you're responding to Jon Favreau.
He doesn't care about Israel-Palestine.
He doesn't care. He never cared.
This dude This guy's become the least
informed
America's least informed political
commentator. He actually doesn't follow
politics. He doesn't know anything. He
is a total [__] Very sad to watch. You
know what I mean?
I'll [__] talk IRI sometimes, but at
least IRI pays attention, okay? I'm not
going to be I'm not going to say IRI
doesn't actually watch politics or
follow it at all.
I don't
Destiny just seems totally detached from
reality when I watch him. It's crazy.
And yes, he did campaign on releasing
the report. And then I'm a giving him
the benefit of the doubt that the report
sucked and was useless and would just
cause more problems and he made an
executive decision not to release it. He
now admits that was a mistake and he
should have released the report. So,
I don't
Dude. Uh-huh.
>> know what
What what are you defending?
It's like a level of being a sycophant
that
like Trumpers do. Like this is how you
end up looking the other way as kids are
getting abused. It's the same kind of
process, the same kind of operation that
happens. Right? You basically are
deciding that it's better for your
political party, your political goals,
to never criticize your own ever. And
that extends to everything. else to say?
Like I want blue maga, but blue maga
doesn't work.
Red maga like maga in the conservative
party works. Blue maga doesn't work at
all. Blue maga is like inherently
stupid.
>> Like he's our leader, he's not going
anywhere. He was elected to be the
leader, he deserves a chance, and he's
admitting to making a mistake, you know?
He said he should have released it. I I
don't think it's the end of the world.
What are we going to do? Just hold it
against him for the rest of uh
the election cycle? I mean,
Well, the guy [__] up on his only
campaign promise and he's totally
failing to raise money for donors and
you guys have your war chest
historically depleted going into the
midterms. Isn't that a problem?
Aren't all of those things problems?
He's like [__] up every major
responsibility he has.
Right? Like what WHAT HAS KEN MARTIN
DONE WELL?
WHAT IS HE DOING WELL ON?
I don't get it. What's what's the
alternative? He's the leader.
Also said they didn't pay the guy for it
yet we pay for. Well, I
I just because they didn't pay somebody
for it doesn't mean they weren't
qualified to do it, and they weren't
an expert and knew what they were doing,
right?
I I just challenge people to support our
leaders.
People make mistakes. People misstep,
but we on the left
lord it over them, and then we refuse to
support our leaders. He won the DNC
chair. He deserves a chance to lead the
party, and if he makes a mistake, it's
okay to call him out, but the same
people who call him out for making
mistakes never praise anything good that
he does, and I think that's wrong. I
don't think that's how you you
get people to support the cause. I think
it's
anytime you're criticizing, you should
also be
um pointing out positive things. If it's
something you care about, otherwise,
what do you Why do you care about it?
He underestimated how weird and
conspiratorial people like Pod Save
America would be about it. I agree.
I absolutely agree.
He turned to
I Is it conspiratorial?
Hold on.
Is it conspiratorial for people to
expect the Epstein files when Donald
Trump campaigns on that?
What do you think, Ira? Do you think
that's conspiratorial for them to say,
"Well, you campaigned on releasing the
Epstein files. You said you were going
to do it." Is that conspiratorial to
expect it?
I feel like that's the only campaign
promise Ken Martin made was, "I'm going
to release that report. It's really
important."
It's uh Holding politicians to their
promises is a conspiratorial belief now.
Self-inflicted wound in a month's time
traction of time that can't afford it.
I agree. He made a mistake, but it did
not impact the results of elections, and
we won with that going on, so
maybe he needs to make
Well, did Ira even listen to what the
original interview was about?
Does he know why they wanted it
released? Does he you why they like
Tommy Vietor and Jon Favreau want this
taken care of.
Does he have any idea?
It is that major party donors are not
donating. The war [clears throat] chest
going into the midterms is insanely
depleted. In a way like never has been
in previous midterms.
That's the problem.
You don't have a war chest going into
those
What was it? The final like 6 weeks
before the election when you spend the
most? You've got no positive cash right
now. You you are literally in debt.
Now you can carry some of that debt and
maybe that's not such a big deal.
But you're not holding money.
You don't got You You ain't got a war
chest, man.
That's a huge deal.
That's why they want it taken care of.
That's why they want it out in the open
so that these donors can get confidence
back. Now I'm going to say probably the
donors aren't getting confidence back
based on this report. This report looks
like every one of their biggest fears
come true
and you might need a leadership change.
That might just be required.
Anyway, we keep going. these mistakes in
order for us to win. I have no idea, but
whatever he's doing is working. And so
for me, this is a nothingburger because
if we were still failing and we were not
taking advantage of the situation and
doing well, then I think the criticism
would be really valid in saying, "Hey
man, this is this is just another sign
of this guy
making mistakes and not doing a good job
and it's time for someone else to take
over." But the thing is we're doing
about as good as we possibly could do
even with this happening. So I It's hard
for me to complain about anything.
You know, it's like
I gave an example of people who lose
weight by eating Cheerios or eating
um
Lucky Charms in the morning. You can do
that. If you can break down your macros
and your calories and you can fit a bowl
of Lucky Charms into your diet, you can
still lose weight.
You can lose weight, but you'd have to
make some sacrifices in other areas cuz
you're probably going to get like 50% of
your sugar.
This is like
somehow you got like a blessing like a
like a MMO blessing that gives you like
minus 1,000 calories in a day. You're
like, "You know what? I'm going to live
my life as if this minus 100,000
calories is going to be there the whole
time."
Minus 1,000 calories is like Maga being
the most cataclysmic event happened to
your country ever.
Right? Like you are winning. You are
winning the diet metaphor by doing
nothing. You can eat like total [__] and
you win anyway, right? But you're not
building up habits for a winning party
long-term. In fact, you're yourself over
completely.
But the analogy works. You're just not
actually executing the analogy
correctly. You are destroying your
habits. You're destroying the way your
party raises money or at least you're
you're not raising money. Maybe maybe
somehow it could end up working out, but
right now, your party's not raising
money and that's a massive concern going
into the midterms.
allowance
for the day in Lucky Charms. Hey Porum.
But you can do it if it keeps you going
and motivated to stick to the rest of
your diet because you get to enjoy that
bowl of Lucky Charms in the morning, you
could totally do it. And then there'll
be people out there who are screaming at
you for eating Lucky Charms. You're
like, "Ah, but I'm losing weight and I
feel better and I'm healthy. Leave me
alone."
So same thing with Ken Martin. He's
winning. He's doing very well. I have
nobody I can't imagine anybody has any
complaints about
the results.
uh released a statement about the
autopsy in conjunction with the report.
I'll just read a bit of it. "When I
received the report late last year, it
wasn't ready for primetime, not even
close. And because no source material
was provided, fixing it would have been
starting over from the beginning. Every
conversation, every interview, every
data set dot dot dot. I'm not proud of
this product. It does not meet my
standards and it won't meet your
standards. I don't endorse what's in
this report or what's left out of it. I
could not
Like,
also, now
when Ken Martin said, "We've got lessons
we took away from this report."
How is he not totally How is he not lost
all credibility?
What he said to Jon Favreau was, "We
took lessons away. We're going to focus
on those lessons." And then he says,
"This report is utter garbage, and
there's nothing to take away from it,
and I stand behind none of it."
Huh?
So, what the [__] What the lessons were
you talking about?
What the lies were you putting out
there?
That's wild. That's wild. Now,
I think Ken Martin's got to go, but it
it has to do a lot more with the Matt
Yglesias article that I read and the Pod
Save criticisms his his total lack of
his
failure to fundraise. That's why he's
got to go. It's not even the report. The
report's bad,
but it's the failure to fundraise. He
can't handle one or the other. He can't
have both.
in good faith put the DNC stamp of
approval on it, but transparency is
paramount, so today I'm releasing the
report as I received it in its entirety
unedited unabridged with annotations for
claims that couldn't be verified. Um
just to give you guys a sense of the
kind of errors we're talking about. On
page 18, the report talks about the 2022
Georgia Senate election and refers to it
as an attempt to quote push through an
unqualified candidate whose job would
have been little more than rubber
stamping the president's agenda. The DNC
affixed a footnote to that passage
saying quote "In 2022, Joe Biden was
president."
>> [laughter]
[laughter]
>> Turn it
Oh, our eyes having a hard time pulling
the broom out for this one. That's not
great, man. That is not good.
How dare you, Jon Favreau, with that
Michael Strahan gap between your two
front teeth? HOW HOW YOU LAUGH at the
DNC and Ken Martin? How dare you? Um
okay.
It's a small detail there. Um so John,
it it sounds like the person who wrote
the report screwed up and it was
useless.
We're
>> [laughter]
>> Yeah, I know. I know.
That's bad though. That's really bad.
I'm still coming through this report.
It's like 200 pages long. What's your
reaction to all this so far? So my first
reaction is like
I want to be careful here because I've
always thought that
people who sort of admit mistakes and
then say, "Okay, I'm sorry. Full
transparency." Like we want to
incentivize that behavior because we
don't want people to think, "Why would I
tell the truth now and release what I
promised I'd release because then I'm
just going to get even more It's going
to be worse because we've had the Like a
nuanced take from Jon Favreau right now?
Oh my god.
>> conversations being in politics. And so
like Ken Martin gets credit, I think,
for doing that. Like it is belated, but
he he he put it out. He apologized. So
that is good. On the other hand,
the more I like read his statement and
read his Substack and then looked at the
report like, you know, he he lied.
Like he's just he was they he promised a
report. Oh my god.
Why? What good comes out of this?
Pointing out the lies to Jon Favreau?
That Jon Favreau is upset that that this
guy straight-up lied to him?
What? Because he probably feels
personally offended.
That he was obviously he was like
basically pointing out the problems and
this guy was lying directly to his face.
What good comes out of telling your
audience that Ken Martin, the head of
the DNC, lied?
What?
Um holding somebody accountable for
lying? What is the value in that? That
that's my question. What what What does
that lead to?
What does that lead to? Could he have
not changed his mind? What do you mean
he lied? When you say he lied, that
means he purposefully misled, that He
did purposefully mislead. Because he
quite literally lied. He lied.
When he said, "We have key lessons we're
taking away from this report." And then
he releases the report and says it's
totally incompetent and we don't about
anything in here. That is a lie. He
knowingly and intentionally lied.
Jesus, man.
>> He never was going to do what he said he
was going to do. You have no evidence of
that. Ken Martin may have had every
intention of releasing this report when
he said he was going to during the
campaigning. And then when he saw it, he
said, "This thing is a disaster. I'm
going to have to go back on my word and
people are going to be mad, but this is
just garbage that's going to hurt us and
I have a duty first and foremost to not
do anything that hurts our party."
Things change. Biden said he would not
pardon his son. Did Biden lie? Does
anyone out there think Biden was lying
when he said he would not pardon Hunter
Biden? I don't think so. I think he was
convinced that Kamala was
That's insanely different. It's
obviously different. That is changing
your mind.
He didn't say
He didn't say, "Oh, what would have What
a What would have been a good thing
there? Or what's a comparison?" It's not
the same. I don't think Biden lied,
actually. I think he had no intention of
I think he went in blind and had every
intention of of like his son getting
through the legal system, the legal
process, like directly.
If he
Oh, how do I put this? I think he just
he didn't think about it.
I It feels different to me, right? It's
different than knowing that you have an
incompetent report and saying, "Well, we
have lessons we're taking away. The
report was fine, but I and I'm
delivering the information from the
report that you need." That's a lie
covering up a mistake.
That would be like if Biden ran for
president and and Hunter already been
convicted and he said he wouldn't pardon
him.
That's that's like the difference,
right? Cuz I think Joe knew that Hunter
might like
get off of that.
You know what I mean? He he knew that
Hunter might be found innocent or could
just get the charges dropped.
And so I and I think he felt that Hunter
had done nothing wrong and that would
happen.
It's like a different thing when he is
faced with reality of his son going to
jail or possibly going to jail and he
can stop it, he feels like he has to do
something. I do think it's different.
Martin is like
he is just lying to cover his ass. It's
way different. was going to win and he
wouldn't have to. And then when Trump
won, he realized
I've got to pardon Hunter. He's going to
get bankrupted by this DOJ.
Either way you slice it,
Ken Martin still lied, okay? Either way
you slice it, Ken Martin still lied. So,
I don't think this analogy works. Ken
Martin's not that kind of liar anyway.
Ken Martin is not the sort of like,
"Okay, I could understand why you would
lie here or why I could I could forgive
you for lying here." Ken Martin just
lied to cover his ass.
It's way different.
>> Jay attacking him and so I'm going to
have to change I'm going to have to go
back on my word and say and do something
that I said I wasn't going to do. But
does anyone think he lied that Biden was
like, "I never planned on doing I'm
always going to knew I was going to
pardon him, but I just told the American
people I'm not going to."
So, I don't think Ken Martin lied to the
Democrats to get elected that he was
going to release the report. I I'm I'm
going to give him the benefit of the
doubt and assume that he genuinely
wanted to release the report thinking it
would be a good thing and then when he
saw it, he said, "Oh, hell no."
He put his incompetent friend in charge
of it. The incompetent friend created an
incoherent product. Then Ken announced
that they weren't going to release the
report
for reasons that had nothing to do with
the truth about why they weren't
releasing it.
Well, again,
these are a lot of assumptions here and
they're assuming the worst in Ken
Martin, too.
And I agree with you guys saying who
cares about this? Why does it matter?
I'm with you. But these guys have It
does matter that he went on this that he
went on a major podcast like this and he
lied openly.
It totally destroys his credibility.
And by the way, all of this is a is a
trap of his own making.
He didn't have to lie.
He could have gone on there and said,
"Well, I don't really like the report or
I don't think, you know, we went in a
different direction away from the
report. We didn't think the report was
good quality." He could have just said
something like this, right? All he had
to say was, "The report was poor
quality. We aren't going to release it."
And then they could have had a fight.
But he said
"The report, it's got tons of work in
it. They did a ton of work on it, okay?
And we got really important lessons that
we are messaging out to everybody
from that report."
That is just an overt lie.
He did it to himself. have dedicated
their lives to calling Yeah, we're we're
we're giving like a action items to all
everybody in the party. We're letting
everybody know about this. We're giving
them all the lessons.
Brother, what?
Lie after lie after lie after lie.
>> Martin for not releasing this report,
completely ignoring the million of
special elections that the Democrats
have won and the kicking of ass that the
Democrats are doing, right? That that
all gets thrown to the side. Instead,
we're going to hyper fixate on this
report that means nothing, will change
nothing, and obviously has had no impact
on the stellar results from this DNC
chair. I could not ask for better
results from the Democrats right now.
And yet these guys want to sit here and
cry about this innocuous thing that
means nothing. Nothing at all. It's the
results that matter.
The results.
Then, when anyone asked about it,
including me, he decided to not just
lie, but gaslight people into being
like, "You're the problem." The You
know, it's a
Why don't you
>> You are the problem. When you're crying
about something that doesn't matter, and
you're not deferring to the guy in
charge who had a change of heart for
whatever reason,
then you are the problem. If you want to
run the DNC, you go run the DNC. But,
I think Jon Favreau would take over as
DNC chair if he could.
I think he wants anybody who's not
incompetent there. To sit here and tell
him that he's wrong and you're right
when you're not in that job and he's
winning,
you're useless. What are you doing?
If the Democrats were losing right now,
you shouldn't just get rid of the DNC
chair. You should like actually
You should actually put them in a
guillotine or something, okay? Not
Obviously, that's not the situation, but
if you're losing to this trumpet man,
all right?
If the DNC were losing special elections
to this trumpet man, holy man.
Holy
That would be a disaster.
Winning right now is almost is
indicative of almost nothing. You are
not running good campaigns. Or Sorry, it
doesn't mean you're running good
campaigns. It means almost nothing.
doing.
Ken could have released the exact
statement along why he wasn't going to
release it. It would have been way
better.
>> I agree.
I think there's plenty of things Ken
Martin could have done that would have
made this better. But, in the end, none
of it matters because we're winning. Why
does any of this matter? There's no
evidence that he lied.
There's no evidence that he lied.
Ira, I just didn't watch the first
interview or something.
Like I guess he just didn't watch the
first interview. This is insane. I What
is Hiral talking about? He didn't lie.
Dude, do I have to pull Hold on. Let's
go find this real quick. Your exact
quote was, "Of course it will be
released." Why did you change your mind
on that?
>> Well, look. I mean, what I said all
along, even when I ran for this
position, is that we were going to focus
on the things that will help us win the
upcoming election. Uh example of some of
the lessons, we've been releasing them
with um our donors and with activists
and party leaders. Man, this sounds so
tricky going back and looking at this.
Cuz like by the letter of the law,
I don't think he's actually quite lying.
I think he's making it very different
that he's learned lessons from the 2024
election, and there was a report.
He's not necessarily saying he learned
lessons from the report, from the
autopsy. He's saying they learned
lessons from 2024, and they're going to
focus on the right things, which are the
lessons. Dude, it's crazy.
Do these people ever talk about
intraparty power politics? If they
don't, who does? It seems like it's
literally just sportsball, team sports
for these guys.
Oh, like they should be. Well, that's
the issue is they're all focused on
Well, at least Destiny and some of the
people around us here focused on like
Hasan and what that means. This is
intraparty politics. This is
like more Biden-ali- Biden-aligned
policy, or sorry, more Biden-aligned
populist types within the DNC sort of
going to war with some of the more
corporate donor heavy, like the people
who are in with corporate donors, like
the guys who run this podcast, the Pod
Save America podcast. These guys talk to
big money donors. And these guys think
the big These guys have been saying the
big money donors don't have faith in the
DNC right now because it's all
incompetence.
And so they've been pressuring this guy
to come out and release this autopsy
from 2024. That's what's happening. It
is an intraparty fight.
But they don't even get All of the
people commenting on this aren't even
getting the good storylines cuz they all
have a different agenda they're pushing.
Like I covered this, and it was an
awesome story. It was like really cool
cuz the information's like
it's not even like public or
it's like public in a way where you see
these people fighting back and forth but
through proxies, right?
And all you have to do is like find a
couple of the storylines and it makes
sense.
But none of the people who cover this in
the liberal sphere at least are covering
it correctly. It's actually really
disappointing to me.
Anyway, yeah. So we've been talking
about what those lessons are and we've
actually been putting those lessons into
action. And so it's not completely
accurate to say that we didn't release
that child. Where we're keeping our
focus is on the lessons that can
actually help us with Oh,
so it's not completely accurate. Oh,
that's bad. That's bad right there.
Cuz he's implying the lessons aren't
derived from the report.
Oh, who are there Yeah, the the guy
who's doing the the heated interview
here. This guy is not really aligned to
somebody in the party. He's more of a
populist type.
But and he's like pushing a lot of money
down into the states and he's spending a
bunch of the money they're raising on
states and getting like state parties
funded.
But before the election like early on.
But the issue is he's spending all of
the money they're raising. Usually what
you do is you raise like a money and you
save it all in your war chest and then
you get to about six
4 to 6 weeks out from the election and
you spend spend spend spend spend. Maybe
even out to 8 weeks. Spend spend spend
spend spend.
All your ads, all of your everything,
right?
And he's he's spending all their money
now so they don't even have a war chest
that's building up and there's a bunch
of people who feel a
a lot of anxiety going into the midterms
because of this.
So
Yeah, the the big money donor types want
this guy out. He's like he's not even
like taking meetings with them. He's
basically saying if you guys don't trust
us then you.
And so this is like pressure from big
big money interests to get this guy out
cuz he's like kind of he's kind of I
don't know if it's like incompetence and
ego mixed together or what it is, but
This guy's a faucet and the donors are
wary cuz he sucks. Yeah, yeah, the DNC
chair should be somebody who's talking
to all the big donors and he's more like
small money donors, right? Like lots of
small money donors, more populist
focused, getting more more more like
small money donors in.
And it's funny cuz a lot of the a lot of
people are aligning this guy with like
the establishment DNC and John John
Favreau with like the populist Bernie
Sanders leftist type people. And that
couldn't be further from the truth.
Favreau was in the Obama administration.
This guy is more of a populist. He like
ran the Minnesota Farmers Party or
whatever.
There's like some
Democrat adjacent party in Minnesota
that's like the the Minnesota Farmers
Party or some [__] right?
I don't even know I don't know what the
[__] it is. I I don't I can't remember
the name.
But people who can't follow politics or
don't understand or or just don't care
are saying because John Favreau gave a
nice interview to Cenk Uygur and a mean
interview to this guy, that means he's
like a leftist or that he's like trying
to help leftist or trying to help
leftist accomplish their goals. That
couldn't be further from the truth.
It's just very silly lazy analysis.
Anyway, we can move
>> Again, I'm leaning on the word lie
because lie means you
purposefully So, we just caught the lie,
right? It would be weird to say we
didn't release the report cuz we're
releasing lessons from the report. Then
it comes out that the report is total
incompetence. It's totally like
it's totally
They're not taking anything from this
report. They In fact, they explicitly
disavow the report. Yeah, now I can say
he's lied.
He obviously lied.
Come on. I do not believe he did that.
Yet, these guys do because they don't
like him for whatever reason or they're
just Democratic Party haters.
I don't know.
I have no idea.
But I do not assume that the chair of
the DNC is lying to us.
who want to win. Why are you looking at
the look in the past? And then there's
like an internal revolt at the DNC and
among donors and DNC members. And so
then they release this. Like it's just
not
He says in his Substack, this is one of
the lessons that he
>> Like Like we see this, right? We see
this.
It's a
He cares about the donors. He cares
about the big money interests. He does
not give a [__] about socialists.
He says it explicitly.
>> internal revolt at the DNC and among
donors and DNC members. And so then they
released this. Like it's just not
He says in his Substack, this is one of
the lessons that he has learned that he
puts in the Substack piece about this
about the autopsy today.
The Democratic brand is in trouble and
needs repair. We have to restore
confidence in our party and show we can
really deliver on our campaign promises
to the
That's the 2024
THAT WAS THE LESSON for 2024. American
people. [laughter] People need to be
able to trust the Democratic Party
again. Trust is critical.
Yeah.
So I Wow, John is steaming. You're so
cringe, John.
He said TRUST IS CRITICAL.
>> [laughter]
>> IT'S SO WEIRD.
Like it's so weird when I actually look
into politics stuff and I spend 5
minutes looking and you just see people
like
embarrassing themselves
over and over again.
So man.
Wow, it's going to take a lot of work
for Ken Martin to regain my trust.
I am I am really steaming about this
one. I don't know. It's I am very
skeptical of Ken going forward.
I think Favreau is of the same mind that
Obama is. They don't want
Like if you ever You guys have heard
this that liberalism basically like
co-opts whatever ideas are good, right?
Whatever ideas are popular like
eventually sort of co-opts them and and
subsumes them.
I think that's what they're trying to
do. I think that's what Favreau is
trying to do. I think that's what Obama
was trying to do when he went and hung
out with
a Zoran?
Right? They're trying to get a lot of
these like more lefty types who are very
popular
to they they want to shift more economic
populist, but they want to do so by
co-opting. They want to bring these
people in, right? They want to subsume
them into the party.
That's That's what they want to do. So,
it's like I don't think it's like a
legitimate interest of oh, we really
want to shift lefty. I think it's like,
"Okay, we need to we need to do
something.
And okay, we'll reach out to these
people. We'll be nice to them and we'll
we'll bring them in and maybe we'll
throw them a bone every once in a
while."
Right?
>> He's going to have to work very hard to
regain my trust. Who gives a [__] about
your trust? He's winning, dude.
Like I don't know what he's doing, but I
want more of it. And so, if you think
he's lying about the report, then he
should lie about a lot of other things
because it we're winning.
Whatever he's doing is working, and I am
happy to get behind it. I have no
arguments, no criticism.
The lack of self-awareness is insane.
His entire job is to make the party look
good as if there's presumably as is
theirs presumably, but all they do is
[__] on him.
No, we
Whoa. Whoa. You know what the best way
to look good is? It's to be good.
That's the best Bro,
this is I If you ever go look at Dude, I
If you ever go look at like, you know,
life coach life advice stuff from like
the mid 2010s,
like people will tell you like
if you look for like style advice, okay?
People will tell you, you know what the
best style advice is? Hit the gym.
Cuz if you're fat, it doesn't matter if
you're like tubby or fat, it doesn't
matter what shirt you wear. It's not
going to look good. The best way to look
good is to be in shape.
Right? That's what the DNC needs. It's
like I I I just wants a
moo moo to throw over this 700-lb DNC.
It's like
how about you hit the gym so you can
wear a T-shirt and look fine?
What is this?
Stop putting Stop trying to put lipstick
on this pig.
We need whip this party into shape, man.
It's time for a Rocky training montage
for the DNC. We have this weird thing on
the left where we think if we're
criticizing we're helping.
I don't know when we came to that
conclusion.
I I I think it's okay to have some
criticisms here and there. It's healthy.
But, boy, that's all we do on the left.
When When is the last time you heard
anyone praising Ken Martin? I I don't
know if I've ever heard anyone say
something nice about Ken Martin.
And yet, the guy's got Democrats winning
in places we haven't won in decades.
He's got turnout similar to midterms in
special elections. He He's got the
electorate moved 13 points to the left
on average and just dominating. And
people will just completely ignore that
he's the DNC chair and has anything to
do with any of that. They won't even
look into any of his moves that he's
made, anything he's done, nothing.
They'll just say he hid the report.
>> Who thinks Ken Martin is the reason
we're winning special elections? Well,
it's not even that. It's It's like not
the DNC either right now. It's not like
the DNC strategy, I don't think.
It Ken Martin doesn't even have like the
the dumbest strategy for what he wants
to do. I just think he can't run the
strategy he wants to run, which is
spending more money further up from
elections in every state, right?
You can't do that without also being an
ace fundraiser, and he sucks at
fundraising. And not in the literal
sense that would be good for
fundraising, in a metaphorical sense. In
a metaphorical sense, he sucks at
fundraising.
similar to midterms in special
elections. He He's got the electorate
moved 13 points to the left on average
and just dominating. And people will
just completely ignore that he's the DNC
chair and has anything to do with any of
that. They won't even look into any of
his moves that he's made, anything he's
done, nothing. They'll just say he hid
the
I know what his moves are. I know that
he's trying to spend money in states and
everywhere, even in states that don't
have electoral seats or not electoral
seats in America, but um
Well, like Guam, Puerto Rico,
American Samoa. He's even spending money
in the DNC in those places, right? I
know what his policies are. I know he's
trying to push money down to make it
more distributed. I know that.
My issue is the lack of fundraising
Although
I think there is something to the fact
that he raised the most in the first
year for a new DNC chair, I still think
the fundraising has been very low given
the threat Maga poses and he's spending
so much money.
Could be good.
But you got to save something in the war
chest, man. You got to do something with
it, right? You got to save something for
right before the election to buy ads.
Can't totally eschew conventional
wisdom. report. Well, maybe he should
hide a lot more reports then because
whatever he's doing's working, man.
Maybe he should hide some more stuff cuz
it's working.
I support it.
I contend that it's fine to call out
lies. And he gets paid so much to just
be like, "Pay no attention to the lies,
guys. The lies don't care about the
lies. Just let yourself get lied to." Al
Braw is such a
is such has been grifter. All he cares
about is numbers.
And I I don't know, but
I don't know about you guys, but the
results matter a whole lot more than
whatever
actions or things he said, man. Like
none of that matters to me at all. The
results mean everything.
Do you think Do you think we've resolved
that? Do we resolve it?
>> know. I mean, so look, I'm with you like
I I'm glad they put it out. I appreciate
that they did this. It took way too
long, but whatever, we're here.
Um I just big picture, I don't think Ken
Martin is the right person to be leading
the DNC right now.
>> [laughter]
>> NO.
NO. [screaming]
NO. NO. NO.
No way.
No way. No way. No.
Bad.
Bad. You step down, [__]
You step down, random podcast dude. You.
Guys,
we're winning by double digits.
It's time Can Martin step down.
It's time.
He needs to do the right thing and get
the hell out of there, and we need chaos
at the top of the DNC right now, 5
months before the midterms. Yes.
I mean, if that's if you get commitments
for donors, I that might be what you
need, unironically. This is This is the
You
slug. You step down from your dumb
podcast, you ass.
You
slug. hole.
I don't even hate IRI, by the way. This
is I like I don't hate IRI. It's It's
honestly just funny to me watch him
talk. You
slug.
>> You
are pathetic.
>> Results don't matter. Not when there's
dark money and no perfect messaging.
Kappa. Exactly.
Dude, these people are lost.
These people are so dude.
Results don't matter.
Brother, you only have Trump here right
now. You only have Trump.
If If you That's your only thing, Trump
is bad. That's all of it. I don't care
about your message right now. I care
about the fact that you guys aren't
fundraising. I care about the fact that
you guys have showed The guy at the top
of the DNC has shown himself to be
incompetent.
If they want to try to hold it together
through midterms, like maybe you do
that.
But my god, if if donors are holding
back their money, like because they're
just scared of this guy, they think this
guy is incompetent, he's just going to
waste it. Like I You're going to [__]
yourselves. You're You have a chance for
like a major landslide here and you
don't want to let it slip away.
You Ken Martin for not being
absolutely perfect and winning by triple
digits and everything. Like dude, in
what world should Ken Martin step
Literally can't win by triple digits
triple digits. Come on, man.
What? Winning by triple digits?
Putin don't win by triple digits, man.
What are we talking about?
>> down.
In what world?
I wish I could use harsher language, but
I've committed myself to not saying
certain words, but I would call these
people all the words, man. I I hate
these people. Everything about them
pisses me off. Can you imagine? It's
like some beautiful girl wants to sleep
with you and she's naked in your bed and
you're like, "Not like this." And you're
like, "What do you mean? I'm here to
sleep with you." You don't mean it like,
"You! I'm out of here."
Idiot.
We need the true tyrant to step down,
the DNC.
>> [laughter]
>> I love it. And and do what? Replace Ken
with what? That's my question. What And
what What will replace Ken? Someone who
will win by even more I mean, I've heard
Wasserman Schultz like literally filled
the coffers massively.
To be honest, I know lefties would
really hate that, but ultimately you
need money right now. I don't know I
don't know what she does now, but I
heard she was really really good at
fundraising.
>> Or who regains your trust? Like it's so
dumb, man. The whole thing is so dumb.
Fair enough.
>> But here's the thing, they would have
found something else to attack him on.
Just like trans people in bathrooms and
women's sports, if you eliminate that,
they'll find something else to attack
trans people on because it's not about
the specific thing. They just latched
onto this to try to attack him.
They don't care. They'll find something
else now that the report's out.
There's also the fundraising problem
that you guys discussed in the
interview. There's some numbers out this
week. The DNC has 14.4 million on hand.
The RNC has 123.9
million on hand.
>> And we're winning by A MILE. SO
>> [laughter]
>> DUDE, THIS GUY IS OUT OF HIS MIND.
That it That That is He's out of his
mind. He's out of his mind. What is
wrong with this guy?
>> Well, maybe we're doing something right.
Maybe that's the right move. The The
Republicans are losing and the
Okay, hypothetically, shouldn't this be
incredibly worrying? You are spending
way more money than the RNC and you're
winning in Yes, some special elections
right now. You're blowing out special
elections,
but you're not saving any money.
So, you're blowing out special elections
special elections,
but you're not saving money and like
isn't that going to possibly look really
really bad?
Like if you guys get to the midterms and
you can't buy ads at the same rate as
the Republicans and it cuts those
numbers massively,
wouldn't you say that's a terrible
strategy?
And isn't that a real concern?
>> The Democrats are overwhelmingly
winning. And yet you're going to crit
Like of course you're the only one
spending significant money right now. Of
course you're winning.
>> Besides the fundraising, it's working.
Whatever he's doing is working. So,
maybe maybe give him an around
IRA is like watching a marathon runner
sprint the first like 500 m of the race,
right? Just sprint full out sprint for
500 m.
And he's like, "Dude, we're winning.
We're What ARE WHY ARE YOU MAD AT HIM?
WHY ARE YOU GUYS SAYING HE'S DOING BAD?
We're winning. He's winning. He's way
ahead." And it's like, "Dude, you got
You got a lot more distance to go, man."
And he like
Everybody can see that this is not a
good strategy. Everybody knows that you
try to be efficient and not sprint, but
they're sprinting and sprinting and
sprinting, it's sprinting.
Dude, that's what it feels like to me,
right?
I
But I I like he has to be smart enough
to see that, right? That that's the
argument. That the the Dems are
sprinting in terms of their spend right
now.
And it's just an uncertainty whether or
not they can win. And if they were
fundraising massively, then you wouldn't
be that upset about it. But they're not
fundraising massively.